Baking is something I'm really bad at.
It's a massive science experiment
that you have to get just right in order to get the right result.
And for me, that's always a hit or miss.
But I really want to learn how to make sourdough bread.
So when my sister flew in,
that was the first thing I wanted her to teach me
how to make a good sourdough loaf.
We got our starter and started feeding it,
and once it was ready,
we made two loafs of sourdough bread.
One thing I didn't know
is how long it would take to do the stretch and folds,
and how it would take up our entire day,
coming back to our dough every hour to stretch it.
But after about four to five hours,
we were all done with the stretch and folds and turned our dough out,
split it into,
and decided on what flavors we wanted the loafs to be.
We wanted a savory and a sweet one.
So for the savory,
we opted for a Parmesan lemon loaf.
And I was craving blueberries so bad,
so we decided to also make a lemon blueberry loaf.
We sprinkle that one with a little bit of brown sugar,
and then started forming it into a loaf
by creating some tension in the dough.
Pop that in the fridge for a little over 12 hours before scoring it
and placing it in our Dutch oven with some ice cubes.
Baked it And it came out so perfect.
Needed a butter,
so we made a whipped brown, vanilla and maple butter,
which went perfectly with how tart the blueberries were.
Our savory loaf was proofing in the fridge for about 48 hours,
so after two days,
it was ready to bake.